foreign
it can get really tricky for sure like
it can get really really tricky
and sometimes when I need to go rescue
people because they get stopped when
they start kind of backing up and then
they go out of the edge
it's just dumping rain which is now
going to impact the road and how the
guests get here
at my restaurant the biggest challenge
for the guests coming is really traffic
not actually if a road is going to be
stable enough to get a car to my
restaurant
but then Rolando tells me they're not
actually coming in a car
I ordered some military boss that
they used to go to the top of the
volcano to bring the people because if
not they would be stopped
but I think they will enjoy it it's part
of the adventure yeah
[Music]
Rolando seems to be just fine he's
laughing about it saying oh it'll be
fine we'll just put 30 people in a party
bus we'll check them up the till he
seems to be going with the flow in more
ways than one here if he's not worried
I'm going to try not to be worried
[Music]
oh people come in oh now they're coming
down the hill there were some
gentlemen's helping the girls that was
like really high heels we may get some
grumpy faces but I don't see no one
falling so I think that's good are they
walking I'm walking
like nice clothes
yes yes this restaurant is remote and
getting there is half the adventure but
Charlie Collins is a very important chef
and trekking through the mud for this
meal isn't the best way to create a
first impression
[Music]